okay for people who are joining this
livestream we are discussing or from
language design our infinite series of
incremental language design meetings
tomorrow we have a more strategic
language design meeting which we will be
live-streaming about um code robust
avocation and error handling and so on
okay today we are starting off with the
echo family right so we currently have
two functions a chronica function with
that structure and we are right now
thinking of adding eco label eco timing
and quiet echo um
okay right so I think the main thing
here is the questioners of whether we
want these only this is a slippery slope
certainly we could add many eco
functions but I think we've always tried
to not to add too many because this is
this shouldn't be are some sort of
debugger functionality right and so we
wanted to discuss with you just a couple
of very tiny questions like for example
the fact that echo function has the
structure function and then label
function I don't remember why we decided
to have label function rather than
function label and so whether echo table
now should have one of two arguments in
the first bracket
you mean if I mean the issue is that
echo label would then be just like echo
function but with a different default is
that correct
that we would make echo label have a two
argument form label coma function which
would then be exactly equivalent echo
function exactly if it had been function
label in echo function it will have a
nicer one late because it was read like
the first argument is because when we
thought of echo function we thought of
it as an operator form and that function
comes from operator form but now I think
we are thinking of it as a go with a
function and echo label would be echo
with a label I separated yeah it doesn't
follow me so much actually I have to say
um I mean basically what we've got is
the three different look we've got X per
label function
I think this is okay an aerco label then
becomes in its inlets it could have this
form label comma function I'm not sure
if we want to support that one right so
that's there
let's not support it let's let's
initially not support it let's just
support echo label of label okay because
I have a feeling we might want to
decorate that label a little bit I see
yep by giving a different cell types or
whatever else okay let's talk about echo
timing right so I could I mean I think
we have discussed it a few times and I
think that's going to be super useful
now the thing with echo timing is that
it might suggest we need the equivalent
for memory functionality like report how
much memory was used during this
competition that's one thing the second
thing is that the first argument has to
be hald first and this is something that
has been suggested in various ways
before like for example people say or
why don't you have a function echo that
prints both what the special was before
evaluation and after evaluation by the
way it sounds like Christopher is gonna
finally show up here maybe we should
come back to this one he's here because
I think he's gonna have direct opinions
about this so why don't we go on to our
next item and come back to this in a
couple of minutes okay so here this
comes motivated from event for enough
let let's make a function repository
function for this okay I don't think we
should canonicalize I don't think we
should turn
is this really true that it that it had
oh I see oh I see I see yeah right so so
I think we should just make this a
function repository function that finds
the canonical form of a Turing machine
rule because there's a there's a
slippery slope of many different
versions of this I think it should be a
function we should have functions going
both ways both from this to the
numerical form and the other way around
and we should do the same thing for
cellular automata and yawns mmm could
you could do that okay it's a good idea
um there are some other things with
Turing machine I've just you know
coincidentally what's in my screen
background here coincidentally my
computer is tied up actually running
giant Turing machine computations so
where Turing machines are in today um
but there are some bugs which I think
Jana M or somebody else should work on
that have to do with Turing machines
with one state on one color and so on
which the Turing machine function is
complaining about hey so that and that's
that that's exactly that corner case so
in the previous section we found in your
book it has been a formula that
generates this rules is what's great so
let's just put it in the function
position and we're good
any problem is this no no no no actually
at the end and the end is one of the
system's whether it was the main
question whether you wanted this in some
hound system or this was a function
I see that's an interesting thing a
property of the Turing machine function
no that won't work we can't have
properties because because we're right
now we're using it as an operator
there's an operator perform of Turing
machine okay so look in terms of the
Turing machine function there's a whole
can of worms to do with
non-deterministic Turing machines let me
let me just we're not going to cover
this I think what we're gonna do one
thing we do need to do is plan to make
multi wavefunction multi way system a
system function protect for 12 - at the
very least
um and that will need some design
reviews would that be like a general
function or what it'll only take like
Turing machines and cellular automata
and so on
it takes substitution systems it takes
almost anything I think it can take it
should be able to take any list of
functions and it will change it should
not just be able to take right right any
any any just yeah yeah any let's see the
problem is let me explain the problem
the problem is it can take any function
that returns a list no that's not
correct I'm sorry that the difficulty is
that it's a pretty complicated function
I mean it has many tentacles that um I
mean but by the way it's heavily related
to nest graph um
except except slightly more efficient
maybe it is heavily related to nest
growth is good but nest graph has some I
mean you should you should learn from
some of the mistakes in the design of
nest graph because nest graph has some
weird stuff were like depending on like
if you have a function that just happens
to return a list right as opposed to a
function that returns a list of
different outputs these get handled
weird ways and it's they're weird things
that nest graph does um to give a sense
though of what happens in multi way
system let's see I'm just going to pull
up the multi way system page
um I mean this is a complicated function
it has many I mean the rules
there's the types of rules that can
handle right now I think it can surely
be more general
yes it presumably can be although what's
tricky here is that some of these things
have multiple outputs not because there
are multiple functions here that because
there are multiple ways to apply a
single function like it's a single
substitution system but the string can
be substituted in multiple ways it's I
mean this is for example what nest wrap
deals with but the semantics of it are
slightly wrong so I mean you would
always just have it so you can give it a
list of functions or a single function
and for every function and it gets it
will assume that that function returns a
list of outputs and not try and do any
voodoo about you know guessing whether
this is a list of outputs or whether
it's a single output that happens to be
a list and then you know right and if
you have the latter case you just wrap
it in lists before you return
so you claim that this is
that's interesting so the other thing
just to mention about Ness graph is that
Ness graph assumes that the function is
non-deterministic so it'll actually run
it many times I believe
you
you're going I mean like if there's if
there's a cycle in the graph yeah or or
if you had like if I have string
reverses my function and I say nest
graph a hundred levels it will actually
run string reverse a hundred times even
though it'll be like I've already been
here before
why should I pause function again it
doesn't in any way I presumably because
it doesn't know the function is
deterministic but you know what there
should be a method option for Nesterov
to say that it's a deterministic
function and cash it
and I think the most common reasons
let's go
yeah was another hose a function is nice
to go for Jose function oh no this is
not mine wasn't making F memorizing I
think yes yes it would but bet it would
be I mean it would solve it but like
there are cases where you can have some
combinatorially like rapidly-expanding
thing where you and if you're memorizing
it it might not be perfectly efficient
like I think you just want to prune like
if F returns let's say that we've
already visited vertices a B and C and
now I call F on you know D and it's and
returns a and then two other q and are
some other new vertices usually just
prune out the a right because otherwise
you get this combinatorial a huge thing
abut just going in a loop and adding
adding to the frontier so to speak okay
so look the the basic point here is we
should get it on our project list to get
multi way system cleaned up and we
should do a designer of your multi way
system cuz I mean right now multi way
system has just a huge number look at
all these things that can produce causal
graphs brown chill graphs look at look
at all these things if you think all of
these are general or these that general
they're all quite general I mean they
arguably they can be repackaged but
things like the coos pendeks completions
and so on those are perfectly general I
mean they you know you can well I think
they're general certainly many of these
things to general weather like for
example the way this package may not be
right it may be maybe should be factored
better
um okay anyway going back to tarnishing
then I'm going to come back to the echo
functions which is
uhh
okay so this was Turing machines with
one state or one color and I really
think that those are wait a minute are
you saying that it's not obvious what we
do in those cases no no I'm saying that
the algorithm that generates their rules
works for those cases so I totally
agreed that yeah I think it's silly I
think that the issue was that you know
and I think the problem is that the
graphics code still draws a little
pointer
I think the Java code should just draw
the pointer up in the case where there's
only one state you know it's fine just
have a little arrow pointing up and it's
always pointing up um I have a rule
brought on dose-response it doesn't for
these piercing yes I have to I should I
should just you know this is the problem
with large overnight jobs is that you
never know when to kill them I mean I've
been running this thing and the fact is
I should probably kill it because it's
probably gonna be it's it's never gonna
finish I I set up something which is
basically way too big to ever finish um
but I just don't have the heart to kill
it so you guys have to UM did you make a
projection about when it would be done
no I didn't I didn't think about it I
was too tired and I just started it off
and went to sleep nice and I got clean
in that notebook which is not a great
size I know I know I know that was me
estimating roughly what could possibly
happen and let me just look at one thing
here I'm just gonna see whether viim the
main challenge here is whether the
whether the data size has gotten too big
seventy nine megabytes that's not that
big ninety nine megabytes not so huge
one hundred eighty nine megabytes okay I
was worried it would get into the
gigabyte range um okay okay well no mind
um got a long way all right maybe I
should just kill it and beep yeah like
I'm gonna run this here um okay so this
is Turing machine I think was gonna
error out
oh it worked huh well his real plot oh
it doesn't it doesn't know how many
states there are oh you know what arid
out is if I only give one of those
you
just doesn't work and there's no reason
that shouldn't work well effectively
that yeah I mean that this should work
and just give one case in the Turing
machine rule and if it if it tries to
run it and it finds a rule it doesn't
have it just says sorry I found a rule I
don't have so I can't go on but the rule
plot shouldn't care okay let let's come
back to the echo um somebody was
commenting Oh with the SpaceX launch is
about to happen hope that goes well um
can we follow that and I assume that our
satellite tracking well that's a good
question
does it have is it tracked by the flight
tracking system that the FAA provides I
I don't know do spacecraft have have
like squawk codes and all the usual
things from planes this spacecraft have
tail numbers something tells me I don't
think that the spacecraft itself has to
talk to air-traffic control but well I
know that they have I mean know that
they have a system for clearing ordinary
air traffic out from the area where
there's going to be a launch but the
question is whether the system is so
standardized that it gets a tail number
and things and it's you know it's some I
don't know a good question I mean it's
it's a good question whether they I mean
I it's obviously on radar so it will
have a it will show up there I don't
know eventually we get the parameters
there oh yeah he'll get the parameters
from NORAD but I think that takes that
takes it passing over wherever the radar
system is that picks those up but I
think it's a good question actually we
should ask the question if they're going
to be so many more of these launches we
should ask the question whether there
should be a feed of launches that are
happening we should probably have a demo
from Alpha can somebody take that to the
Geoff presumably is the right person to
ask
yes um
[Music]
saying spacecraft require permission
from the FAA affair may not track it but
NORAD certainly does yeah absolutely but
I Nora
better be doing that that was the
original mission during the Cold War it
was um but I don't know whether our feed
I I thought that our feed was based on
well I don't know we'll find out
maybe somebody can ask gum is right
Brian is saying that um the feed from
NORAD will be delayed just like for
commercial air flights yeah yeah what we
we um I mean that's a very confusing
thing because you can afford project the
vectors um assuming that the thing aids
all rather confusing um
actually week is a little bit more
complicated what actually happens there
um okay let's come back to echo
Christopher we were talking about echo
and we were discussing echo timing and
the question of what it actually does so
it's a whole first function unlike the
rest of the echo family right but Jose
you were you were just saying something
about a proposal for echo timing yes so
they the thing is that until now our
echo functions were not hold first so
fun echo timing is the first one that is
hold first and it has been requested
other times that we have more of these
holes first echo functions that - for
example for example to print both the
expression before evaluation and after
evaluation and thinking about these
would realize that we have a similar
idea in the other function called paired
which we wanted to have paired
expression comma F returning the
expression and F of the expression yes
so the question might appear there - do
we want pair to be hold first so that F
can't receive something before
evaluation and can we mix paired with
echo to achieve multiple things so I
mean at some level what is the advantage
to some like okay what would be the
advantage to some sort of echo paired
thing over just writing echo of f of X
right like just write echo twice that
makes sense yeah yes so one thing was
for example in echo timing is that we
don't want to evaluate the expression
twice and so by evaluating absolute
timing of the expression we get from the
result the result okay so we have what
goes in what comes out so the only issue
is a sandwich there that would say what
would be the sandwich here the sandwich
would be
seekers pair does is not I don't
understand what is there an echo of
paired no I don't think so because I
think what we want is the echo before
before and after like this so this is
like a sandwich this could be a you know
it's like an echo sandwich although
that's not a very good name but but a
factor integer would do the equivalent
of that so only D is is what we have a
later on this paired definition in which
their first argument is held so we can
use them paired of a function to print
both the expression before the valuation
and after evaluation unfortunately it's
the wrong order but you have both there
I see the pad I see this case here
exactly
okay but let's talk about echo timing
for a second what we actually want it to
do because we might want to print the
expression we might want to print the
timing and we might want to print the
time into the evaluation and we might
want to just annotate echo I mean for
example we might want to how would we
annotate echo with the time so far in
the computation well you can use echo
you know echo has a second argument
which is the label I know that but how
will we get the time so far in the
computation well basil waiting multiple
times to complaining I don't know how
you do that I mean there's there's in
other words no but well yes but I mean
in terms of design but how do we
actually do the computation that is in
the beginning of mission with so what is
the what is then sorry well I'm saying
if you'd said timing of blah blah blah
is there a function you can call inside
the the function you're inside the X bar
so that it says since this outer timing
was called this amount of time has
elapsed or do we know I mean it's only
time elapsed since when since shift
enter
or so since since the evaluation of
timing began so in other words what I'm
thinking is a start timer or or you know
timing block of and then it's you know
pause of one and then echo time so far
and then onward would be one that would
be one yes by me it some of what you
only really care about the relative
times right I mean but most of the time
you just care that you know you don't
care exactly when it started but you
just care to see this happen and this
happened one second later and this
happen one second later etc I mean it's
I mean if you don't show a giant number
where it's like the unix time or
something no no I agree that's why I'm
suggesting this the time I mean not the
timer at some of although I think that
this serve defeats the point of having
it be echo timer because the whole echo
timing or whatever it's called because
the point of echo is that you don't have
to add a bunch of stuff into your code
oh I agree completely I'm saying this is
a different functionality I mean echo
timing would be the purpose of echo
timing is an inward-looking thing that's
is simply asking for exper reflect the
timing of x-bar yeah in other words show
how much time it took to do that so I
would assume that echo timing would be
pretty commonly wrapped around a
complete expression well I mean let's
let's see do we have an implementation
is working okay fine so I can just say I
could say basically table echo timing
factor integer to the minus one and then
I just doing a table there and 20 or
something
that's rather ugly and why is there a
double column now the general utilities
timing exactly yeah
and what's this this is the general
utilities function we have actually
eliminated this function because the
code I mean does this better now
well how do I run the new record timing
it's presenting twist to okay okay fine
a lot about my 12 to is not gummed up
running Turing machines um
I don't even know how I was managing to
run this echo timing here I I like the
fact that it's showing microseconds
that's cool what is this maximum echo
rate exceeded is that relevant to our
current discussion or not I just think
so I think this is something that
utilities does it has a maximum of 10
per second it would not print more than
10 per second if the useful
functionality I was that Italian thing
and why did he read it because it once
we are following in time something this
looks more like a monitor thing like a
funnel
okay so there's that code timing who do
we like those very tiny times I guess
you're not really gonna see tiny times
most of the time the case we're gonna
use this is where these times aren't so
tiny um okay so what this did was it
didn't it evaluated only at the moment
of timing its using the timing function
it's not using absolute timing is that
correct so if I were to do this on
solute timing by default oh it does yes
um
I think in general people care much more
about absolute timing they care about
timing but it is sort of an unfortunate
naming thing because the name echo
timing does kind of imply that you want
timing instead of absolute timing but it
would be kind of ridiculous for to use
timing should we be deprecating timing
in flavor of absolute timing because
because you know maybe timing has become
meaningless and modern in the modern
world I mean it was it was designed at a
time I mean I don't even know when it
when we're calling library link
functions do they are they included in
timing I so sorry I sure that math link
muslin calls are not included but I
would guess library link they are
because I mean it is the kernel like it
is is the same process and so on
protocol counting toward CPU time of the
I mean I would argue it is probably
still useful like it shouldn't be
deprecated but I mean well maybe we
could change the default we could make
timing be absolute timing we could have
a method option because what concerns me
is some thoughts make a lot of things
but yeah I think it's a bit too late to
change that well but what about all the
sub process timing we never managed to
get we had a plan like 5 or 10 years ago
to have WS TP you know math link
processors pass-through sub process
timing information and so on but that
was never implemented and I have no idea
when there's multiple threads going on
and so on had no idea what timing
reports mean the only thing that seems
to me to make sense is the absolute
timing of you know what came out you
know how long did it take wall clock
time for something to come out I don't
even know what what does CPU time Inc
mean I think this is well-defined like I
think OS is know right like so for
example there's the unix time command
which still works and you know will will
measure your CPU time and so on so I
mean I think that does it measure well
it measure it has three outputs it has a
user which is like
no it has yes wall clock time user time
and system time I think that's what I
remember says but yeah but what what but
I don't know I think it's some OS to
find thing I would guess you know which
is what timing hopefully uses yeah the
documentation for timing suggests that
it's OS dependent on certain operating
site but I mean so we could find some or
it may right but we could we could
redefine that I mean we could perfectly
well defined timing going forward to be
wall clock time because I just think
it's getting so undefined what um
OSS have a definition I mean the
argument for it's undefined so therefore
we should do something I think that
usually comes in the case of like it's
undefined we don't know what to do but
there is a well-defined thing to do and
that is just use whatever the OS says
and so I don't think that there's a
reason to do that and it would probably
break a bunch of existing stuff I mean
this is sort of the cop-out thing but
you could always just sort of say over
the code assistance project you know
have a little thing are you sure you
don't mean absolute timing and someone's
this time because I think that's the
that's the only real problem is that
people who don't know Mathematica very
well right timing when they mean
absolute timing what does this mean this
this is time you taught is this a
different time this is the unix time
function isn't it yes so what is it
saying here
total time elapsed oh the time consumed
by system overhead the time used to
execute to the standard error stream
okay what the heck does that mean the
time used to execute it I mean if you go
to your you know your computer does have
a well-defined thing of CPU time how
much CPU time is such a process used
what does it do inference
what does it mean when there are
multiple threads operating I think it I
think it sums them like I think that you
can have I think I've seen I'm pretty
sure that you can have a function where
the user time is longer than the wall
clock time because it's running on
multiple cores I see so that so the user
time so what does timing do with respect
to multiple threads so if you say if you
say timing of parallel parallel evaluate
of pause of one on four kernels it will
say four approximate I I don't think it
will because I don't think timing I
don't think parallel works with timing
okay okay sure but if there's a function
that internally use some other yeah okay
yes at least it's supposed to this could
be platform dependent believe it or not
but it is supposed to sum over all
threads this is very troubling to me
that I I think I'm running my whole
giant Turing machine adventure and my my
kernels are only using 0.1% of my CPU
they're either finished or they're
completely i/o bound which is really odd
um sorry never mind so show me there'll
be a reason to look at this the CPU time
they're in compared like the system time
or something but well let's take a look
let's see what the let's see whether
this is you're arguing that that these
things aren't useful percent of the GPU
ok so so well let's take this as an
example where's the PID where is the
pain right ok you see it does it does
also list CPU time oh I see oh it does
yes all right but it's only using 0.1%
of the CPU which is really suspicious um
seven one eight three six so so this
should be I should be able to say in
here system process data um if this all
works correctly someone eight to six
why doesn't that work this is probably
going to leave give some giant data
structure which okay so this has system
time user time etc so presumably I can
say here I mean just just for the sake
of because I wanted to bug this anyway
but it also helps me to understand
what's going on can I do that yes I can
okay all right so these are then
launched
okay so what am I supposed to understand
here so the system time is really low so
that means it's not IO bound well and
the and the real time is immensely high
which oh that that's because it was
launched it's a parallel kernel that was
launched ages ago but it hasn't been
spending much CPU time it's really weird
well okay but who knows what went wrong
but maybe one of them is spending all
the time yeah that's possible on a
different machine um anyway okay so what
do we learn from this this is and that's
got running on 11 threads so given that
it's running on 11 threads this user
time
sums up the contributions from all those
threads is that right
even though those may be happening
simultaneously anybody know I mean this
is completely non-committal about yeah I
think that's what it does
or actually I don't know about threads I
mean I think it's with cords I don't
know how that like I said yeah and then
there's questioning genuine cause versus
fake cause and so on yeah I don't know
how that works
okay so Brian our live stream is saying
the process time counts the sum of the
values from all of its threads okay each
thread tracks
okay so the claim is that the OS is
tracking the number of CPU clock ticks
not spent idle
and allocated to this process presumably
okay so I mean it's a slightly
complicated story then and III really do
think we should consider the possibility
that we simply define what timing means
because I think it's becoming undefined
but well I would find dangerous to
change the meaning of timing
but what would help a user certainly is
to renamed timing to CPU time in
something like that because they do get
confused if if there was only absolute
timing and CPU timing they will be
forced to choose I see what you say but
if people just want timing I mean they
just want something that gives them the
time it takes to run something which I
think to them I mean if we had CPU
timing an absolute timing and then we
made timing change its default I don't
understand why you think it will break
anything because there might be people
who are using this function in a in a
true way why I mean how how why would it
be different in other words in what case
would it be well-defined to have a
difference between absolute timing and
CPU timing well you know for example I
have these codes to do computations and
sometimes they go out to sea and do
things there and I have used the
difference of timing and absolute Tammy
because I know that that VMs link timing
doesn't count okay so you're using the
fact that this is in fact something that
yes but you see that that's you're
you're using it incorrectly because we
wanted it to count through math like we
just never got around to implementing
that well they do say both absolute
stunning and tiny and then look at the
difference no I understand that but my
point is this
my point is timing right now has a bug
that it doesn't include WS TP sub
processes as far as I'm concerned I can
see that bug so you're gonna see it
about like I see I said this was a
feature no I don't think so I think it's
a you know I think that I mean if we
look at the documentation for time
um the other thing is I think comparing
I mean comparing sister tight you can
comparing timing and absolute timing oh
sorry
is it better now no oh maybe something
went wrong for me okay anyway good okay
well I mean comparing timing and
absolute timing like mr. IP I think it's
dangerous disconnected some microphone
or something because you just yeah I can
try research I got here a Cousteau serve
anyone oh okay well okay problem with me
okay
good keep going I was just gonna say
that I think numerically comparing you
know the wall clock time in the cpu time
also seems like it's a little bit
dangerous because you know again if
you're running with multiple threads or
something like that these could be just
totally separate things but yeah I mean
I I agree that I think then I have to
imagine that there are places where
people use timing and they mean it
well okay so look on this this basically
says we don't know whether it's going to
use different things from different
threads
times mminton external processes
all right well whatever okay let's come
back to echo timing I think I still
think this is a mess and should be um um
should be locked up but okay let's come
to echo timing and how it's supposed to
work so what do we have on hum
so what is the issue here the issue is
this is a timing function which does not
evaluate its argument is that the main
question well I think in my opinion echo
diamond is correctly designed with the
default between absolute timing in the
method we might want to call that
optional timing function by analogy to
distance function distance function
mm-hmm but apart from that I think it's
it's fine so the question here is
whether to have some more general
mechanism of allowing users to intercept
before the valuation the expression and
then provide a function that can do a
bit early things and as long as long as
it provides a pair result come up
information we can print the information
and return the result so that's why
thing is connected to pairs yes I
understand
so you're saying this is an echo held or
something that takes or held echo
you're saying that it's something like
this where it says where there's an F
here or timing for example
and where when this is executed okay so
let's just look at what this might look
like so you're saying that might be it's
essentially held echo function of this
is that right yes even though once we
put it in operator form we have the
problem of how do we hold who's the
holding the table like this it's not
quite the same as echo function because
you're not going to print the output of
timing you're gonna print just the first
argument of the result and leaving a
second you are printing the results of
timing right no that's the first
argument of timing that gets printed and
the second argument of timing is what
gets returned by echo timing right so so
in it will be more like hold a compare
function because the function you are
providing is a pair function that has to
return a pair exactly you say what pad
what do you say so more than held a KO
function is a held echo per function in
the sense that it's like fault pair et
cetera we have functions that must
return a pair because we will do
something different with the first
argument and the second oh I see what
you're saying
timing is returning a pair I got it yes
in there mister what you're saying yes
that's a big messy thing it's a powerful
idea and that's all so did the other two
have consider for pair
yes so the point is that you're gonna do
an evaluation you're gonna get a pair
back one of those pairs is being echoed
and the other is being fed on for the
next operation so what is the
generalization of that idea the
generalization of that idea and it not
unrelated to the nest graph and all
those kinds of things some function
produces X Y and then
there's a side effect on X but you're
gonna use why it's correct this is the
same type of idea we discussed for full
/ Leopold Perlas works in this way right
right
we created things like take table etc
what do you mean well take a drop is
another example of a function that
commits to return a pair always you mean
that this could could have a take drop
in it slightly this does that what does
that do my confuse here you know you
would have to use the so they put to the
list or put another list like range one
two three four you need that you need
the first listen there comma least one
two three four after range to sir after
Princeton
and for so it's taking and drop in and
such taking again I am very confused by
this okay so let me wrap an echo what do
I is that even I don't even know what
that's doing
hush hush
now by the way in this case it will be
useful to me to see and by the way
that's not gonna work is it and having
to go sequence well that's an
interesting problem so that would be an
echo function over of this and now the
syntax cholera fails well you could just
get it list couldn't you like a function
of list of trash yeah okay fair enough
we're in here oh come on yeah applied I
don't know if I can actually take
multiple arguments no I don't think it
can anyway okay okay that's not the
relevant thing to this but the most
important thing here is this is a way of
having a pipeline normally we would
compose functions F of G of H of X etc
etcetera but this is a way of composing
functions where the functions are where
H is returning X Y and we are only
getting the Y to feed on in the pipeline
and the X is being side affected away
yeah so
that feels like some kind of headdress
to H
you
right literally parrot is it just pad
but but but prepare doesn't side effect
it away paired generates a list this is
more like a do pad as in what we're
saying is um if H right if H is or it's
some kind of curry like thing because
what it's doing is it's taking H of X H
of X is gonna return two things one of
them are gonna throw away and one of
them we're going to we're going to do
two things will we're going to take that
and to the you know eventually what
we're gonna do is H is going to return a
B and then we're going to apply some
function u to a for example and we're
going to return B so the result is this
is so how do we specify that so
I actually have to go I have another
meeting in like just a few minutes oh
okay okay all right
well see ya
well okay so again back to echo timing
so I think there are two different
problems here one is making echo timing
more powerful so that can handle threats
and we all say that the other thing
which is the discussion suggested there
is how to link echo to pair and in my
opinion the key idea is to make pert
echo hole first
I think if paired was holed first but I
wasn't planning we would make it more
powerful because it would be able to
handle expression before evaluation is
it going to cause weird I mean generally
it's a big threshold to make something
hold first indeed yes yes that's that's
why I'm I don't know I don't know the
but but you can't do this with pad can
you let's you have a third argument is
like the thing that gets the a comma B
and then it's up to you to decide what
you want to do with a and B and really
its echo timing is essentially it's a
wholly general you could put anything in
the timing function it doesn't really
have to be returning a timing for a and
the result for be the timing function
whatever you put out no I understand but
timing happens to do the same thing that
paired does that is it returns an expert
and an f of X / yeah F is the side
effect of is the timing thing so what is
consuming pad what is your idea for how
we consume the pad which is what I was
talking about here for example would get
map paired and and get some sort doors
this is what I had this is what I have
now
yeah no I know what paired is full but I
don't understand what the relationship
between paired and what you want to do
with echo is because what you want to do
with echo is take one elements of the
paired and then feed return the other
element the
take one element and echo it and then
return the other element so so the
example would be for a bit further down
when it prints both because so the
original thing is that users have asked
several times already how do I print
both what I had before and what they
have now yeah I understand that was my
echo sandwich thing
actually it's not even an echo sandwich
it's it's worse than that it's an echo
with a before evaluation after
evaluation well you see that by having
pair to hold first we can already do it
even with echo function no I see that
but okay so what you're proposing is
that we're saying echo function of pad
right and then we put there what do we
want to do with this no this doesn't
work on evaluated of expression right
who but even that wait a second so what
this is then doing is it's taking pad
you have paired of something there's the
four function and so we're going to
print expert and f of X / yeah I
understand this is really complicated
and weird I mean I understand so that's
gonna give that's gonna be in the
opposite order it's going to be X /
result result and then it's going to be
hold of input right look I think you
know an echo before after
or something that could be wrapped
around an expression would clearly be
useful I mean that that would give you
the
you
am i confused here I mean it seems like
that would be useful and then that would
be an echo that would be formatted to
just show um you know just like echo
formats like that we would have
something that would show a before and
after with different colors or something
like this
you
we can do transpacific certainly this
our way of now whatever if we have echo
before after there's a question of what
what matches with what because the
before could be echoed long before the
after comes out so I'm saying they'll
nest we don't want to do that I don't
think that's a good idea I think it's a
I think it's a better idea I mean that
could be conceivably some weird method
option for echo before after I agree
that this is a really useful debugging
thing to see before after I mean when it
echoes the before it would be implicitly
held right right I suppose what we would
do it would have a hold form probably
better before would have a hold form so
that if you copy it it doesn't explode
in some sense it's like saying that the
label is the expression before
yes something like that although I think
we wouldn't want to do it that way I
think what we would want to do is some
kind of thing how would we match them up
how would we match up because we
certainly know I mean well we can know
with a sort of UUID type thing I wonder
whether we could format it so that it
actually has a bracket connecting it and
that'll be really cool if we could do
that right because they can be nested
yes exactly and this is a very useful
function but there Brian on live stream
is suggesting echo the red for
presumably the pairing undo ah
that makes sense oh I see echo no iCal
thread would be echoing I'll be
threading across this list but I don't
think that's quite the right thing look
I really like the cycle before after
thing which I I mean maybe that's not
the right name um
wait too long but yeah it would be a
great to have something specific um
okay but so let's come back to echo
timing for a second what we're doing now
it's very obscure that echo timing just
says you know times here
it's very obscure cuz it it's like how
do you
if I were to do this thing here and can
I put a label in there yes it's the
second argument in fact good timing
I see so I could put an end
you
hmm that's interesting that's nice okay
I guess question is do you want this to
display in units I don't know where as
is I kind of think as is because I think
what you want is maybe it's an option
for echo timing I'm not sure
Indian evidence have to change today in
their methods function yes that'd be
okay quantity something-or-other
quantity that's a decent idea
um
I played that might be a way out of your
previous discussion if we introduce a a
new timing function would excuse that it
returns quantity yes so timing and
absolute timing come prepared if that
makes sense what do you mean by pad they
already inherently return a pair they're
not a function that you would need to
wrap paired around it
I see what you're saying yes so I guess
whatever this function is does it
require the user to give it a function
that returns a pair explicitly and user
themselves would go home echo holder
echo pair that eats an expression and
you want to echo something but return
something else
so you're I see so what you're proposing
is so let's just be clear there are two
functions we've got we've got echo
before/after which is a fairly specific
case and then we've got echo pair which
would take so echo pair would expect
that it is going to be given an
expression and a a an echo basically
that's what it thinks it's gonna be fed
echo paired sorry thinks it's gonna be
fed that
and it is essentially it is like echo
function with the hash too
that write a check follow I think this
would be more like experimentation and
then we expect that s of expert returns
okay so I think there's like three
possibilities maybe there's echo pair
that gets a pair itself right but you
might also want to have instead the
first argument like some function first
argument is expert second argument is a
function right so this would be this
would echo pair of timing would then do
the right thing yeah but there's a
separate thing which is more like echo
pair function where you just give it
time
yes and potentially also you could do
expert comma timing not just the
operator form yes I guess my question is
timing is a function that is already
paired indeed so is the design that you
would give something that is a pair to
function every time into that or do we
want a function where you would give it
an F and it would do the paired for you
well I mean that's the different thing
it's kind of a shame that timing and
absolutely timing come prepared I've
often wanted to just get the timing and
not return the result
indeed so if there was a paired back
then and maybe timing and absolute
timing would have returned that no but
well okay so you're saying we're talking
about new timing functions yeah yeah
okay so you're saying that if I said um
let's say the time which would be the
thing that just gives me the time right
you're saying that this would do what
you are now proposing echo timing does
right pad returns
salt and then the time of Expo
yes I think that trend in the model of a
compare receiving a pair yes I also
think that Ian was complaining about the
order but that might not be so difficult
to change with reverse applied stuff
pretty weird um I I think there's two
things there is a function that eats a
pair and then there's a function eats an
expression and a function that produces
a pair so there's like echo pair of an
explicit pair okay pick up all the pair
yes but then there's like echo timing
does not accept a pair it accepts an
expression and a function that you use
to generate the pair
it's a method option yeah okay fine yep
and then app that potentially has its
timing function in it
so echo timing could just be generalized
where the timing function is instead
just a second argument and it doesn't
need to be a timing function it just
needs to be something that returns a
pair right so this is what earth would
that be cold um I'm gonna call it echo
side but that's a horrible name where
that with with the this um for example
you'd put timing there right where P
returns a pair and so one example of
that would be echo side of expert pad
impaired has an operator form so pair
the bath would do the right thing
correct rate yes okay is there another
and then we've also talked about echo
before after it's not related to these
or is that something yet different and
and so before we echo side also I what
if there was a different version where
you just give it F and it does the
paired for you but I don't know which
one we prefer given that absolute timing
and timing already returned a pair but
like okay so there's a possibilities
like a total memory use or something
that just returns the memory so you
would have to do paired of that so x
becomea g and that's equivalent to echos
side of exper paired of g right is can
we write echo before after in terms of
these other things
no because these echo pair is echoing
just the second member of the pair like
to echo before after is echo of
the first member of the pair and
returning the second one how do we do
that how do we do that could you tell
boss I mean it can't print anything we
want and then return it returns the
after returns look it's got to
definitely returns the after and prints
both the before and the after right at
the same time know when they when
they're available right what that's what
you want for a KO before after what I
mean is that with the previous functions
we could do something that prints both
at the same time yes one of them but
it's somewhat obscure yes it's what you
have on the left it's doing that thing
right yes this horrifying thing here
yeah yeah I mean that's pretty horrified
the operator form of paired would have
to return a pure function right yes yes
oh boy okay this turned out to be much
more complicated than expected I have to
go to something different here come can
you guys have a further think about this
and let's discuss this more I think
there's some very interesting functions
here
you
oh boy that's unfortunate Oh in
terminals but but but I don't have to
see that in and like what I'm doing yeah
we talked to Roman he says he can
provide a variable that will allow the
right thing in Lux okay okay fine
all right okay good good thank you all
thanks to folks on the life this is the
simple it's very simple
why wouldn't that just work
Oh am I it's going to go in the order
and inside the Association yes I think
this is doable it's just a feeling of
adding arbitrary things in in
associations we have to talk about it
sorry we have to talk about it okay all
right okay to be continued another time
all right thanks guys see you later